joining me now rob smith former army
veteran host of the podcast rob smith is
problematic and author of always a
soldier
and also jack carr former navy seal and
author of
the devil's hand gentlemen thanks both
of you for being here
um you both served you've led with men
you've been in combat
uh rob let me ask you did you is this a
systemically extreme problem we have in
the military today
no it's not and first of all let's
define what extremism really is right
so in 2009 an uh an army major named
nadal hassan
went in fort hood texas shot and killed
13 of his fellow soldiers
and injured 30 more now that is the
deadliest terrorist attack that has ever
happened on a u.s base in history
right so this is a person um that was
radicalized by radical islamic terrorism
so that is the kind of extremism that we
used to have to
keep an eye out for um and root out in
the american military
now the kind of extremism that they are
defining right now bishop garrison and
people like him
this is not extremism this is the what
they're using to sort of purge political
enemies
um what they're defining as extremism
this sort of patriot extremism white
nationalism whatever
this is nothing of the sort these are
pretty much milk toast center-right
republican-leaning people
who may have voted for president trump
may have voted for other republicans
and may have said as much on social
media so they are only using this right
now
to pretty much purge the military of any
political enemies and to them
a political enemy is anybody who is not
a liberal or on the left
and to me that is dangerous for free
speech and it's also dangerous for the
soldiers that are serving
because they're open to the real kind of
extremism that i told you about earlier
exactly right jack were you familiar
with much of this i mean we've we've
heard about kind of the wokism
and the reading list and some of that
but i didn't know much about bishop
garrison until we started until we
started looking into this these working
groups how far it will go
does it surprise you it doesn't surprise
me today but
uh in over my 20 years in naval special
warfare if we were extreme about
anything or if i noticed any extremism
it was we're extremely focused on the
mission and we're extremely focused
on the task at hand because that's what
we owed the country that's what we owed
the mission the guys to our right and
left
uh that's what we were extreme about
nothing else um
and really the job of the united states
military is to prepare
for war yes so that when we get called
to go to war
we are ready and then we go and we
execute the country's business uh
everything else that detracts from that
mission uh there's there's something
else at play there that's for sure
but i mean where does this mindset come
from rob that
you know if if someone uses the wrong
gender pronoun they can't have your back
in a firefight you know i mean
nobody's perfect everybody has different
political views
the military's always been a melting pot
truly of people of different backgrounds
rich poor black white where does this
sudden mindset come that
these types of people patriots or people
that supported trump
they gotta go they're dangerous
well where it comes from is first of all
like i said they have a rush to define
all of their political enemies right now
as extremists um like i said defining
trump supporters general conservatives
etc
but this also comes from the far left
woke stuff if you want to call it the
critical race theory people
any of that stuff the problem with a lot
of this stuff is that it ascends to
positions of power as of right now what
we are seeing
with this bishop garrison person now he
is influencing policy in the united
states military
so this is where all of this stuff comes
from i do some work like i said with
turning point usa on college campuses
it all starts there but it honestly ends
up in the halls of congress
as we've seen um it ends up in the
pentagon and it ends up
very very very close to power which is
what we're seeing right now
and stuff like this will destroy the
military from the inside out
if it is not if a light is not shown
upon it jack let's look forward a little
bit so let's say this working group
comes out with recommendations
and they are at or near as extreme as
the type types of things he's talked
about
what in what way does it is a general
today able to reject
that or is the general class effectively
going to have to say
hey if i don't accept that whole cloth
then i'm the racist so i
better do it well that's exactly right
and what we see in the military
as i'm sure you saw is that when you hit
a certain rank
uh these guys sometimes turn into
politicians and they're they're signing
the
the deal for raytheon or whatever else
is seeing their buddy who's on the board
that got out of the military a couple
years
before so there is this military
industry that's a real thing that
military industrial complex so asking
our senior level leaders
who are essentially just politicians in
uniform to stand up to this stuff that's
expecting too much from these people and
in the early 60s the trust in the united
states government
was at an all-time high it's steadily
deteriorated
since then but what happened is the
military trust in the military started
from the end of vietnam
and uh especially from 1980 on uh the
trust was there and what we're seeing
here is the erosion
of trust in the united states military
just like we're seeing it
with supreme court issues with the
supreme court but that is i think
what the other side is trying to do is
to erode that trust in this instant this
trusted institution
uh and when we're talking about vetting
people before they come in
it's not just what they like uh your
interview with laura logan last night
about the surveillance state
everybody should listen to that it was
amazing but uh just what you
hover above they know exactly where your
leanings lie
without even having how harrowing is
that your kid right now
interested in politics makes a few
comments here or there wants to join the
military and they say
sorry you look like an extremist to me
kid go to go to college
it's amazing uh rob smith jack carr uh
we really is dangerous times thank
thankful for men like you appreciate it
hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else